hey what's going on is Bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and just checking in on you
how's it going how are you how's your
week going all that's wonderful I know a
lot of you guys last Monday were very
upset with me when I was speaking in
code and you just could you know about
my European tour you're like oh wait a
minute it rhymes with bond in England
well where the hell would that be I'm
not some sort of sleuth I can't figure
that stuff out I got to start breaking
down code this isn't what I signed up
for I signed up to listen to an angry
half a leprechaun you know [ __ ] about
getting a sunburn all right well I can
actually announce some date I don't know
why I can't announce all of them I don't
know what the big [ __ ] secret is it's
not like I'm going to go over there to
start spying on you but here's the ones
we got so far
actually that the tickets are going to
go on sale I think out of [ __ ]
Sadie's places Costin Co L sto n Hall in
Bristol UK announced 525 at 10:00 a.m.
all right so the tickets are on sale oh
I just want to announce it
well I'm announcing it on the 26th the
tickets will go on sale on may 27th at
10:00 a.m.
BST whatever the [ __ ] that means Britain
Standard Time I don't know Billy's
stupid tits I have no idea you can get
those at live nation.com artist slash
bill bird - to whatever the link is on
my my website that's going to be August
3rd on August 4th I'm going to be in
[ __ ] match Manchester England home of
Man United I'm going to be there on
August 4th and those tickets will also
go on but tickets go on sale on the 26th
that's the presale
to sell subscribers only whatever the
[ __ ] that means I don't know what any
[ __ ] mean for all you normal people
I guess who don't have cell phones for
all the old people tickets for everybody
else will go on sale on May 27th at
10:00 a.m.
Billy stupid tits time
August 5th where am I going to be next
I'm going to be in London England at the
Apollo
Hammersmith these things go on sale and
once again May 27th at 10 a.m.
Britain Standard Time god save the
queen' time I don't know
an August 8th I'm going to be in
Edinburgh Scotland the folks to [ __ ]
plod coast up sorry to that accent up
Pleasants grand to shows there I think
I'm doing - in London - I can't remember
I don't [ __ ] I don't pretend to know
these things those will also go on sale
on May 27 - 10 a.m. all right I got some
dates I got three dates in Ireland - and
I got a something in Amsterdam I think
that'll be it nice little 10 day [ __ ]
run there go over there you know stare
at you pasty conscience see where my
freckles came from that's what I'm doing
oh I can't wait I cannot [ __ ] wait
you know we are knee-deep neck deep into
right in this season we got the table
right here in a couple hours for episode
5 episode 5 then we do 6 7 8 and June
and then 9 and 10 and July and then we
[ __ ] edit them for the next 10 months
not even 10 months whatever for the next
six months will be admin always [ __ ]
[ __ ] will basically have them and then
they'll come out May of next year and
you guys will sit down with a six-pack
of beer and you'll burn through them in
about three hours
that's an envier what it [ __ ] the next
one and you know what we'll make you
some more because we're having a great
time but I'm not gonna lie to you it has
become my life and I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on
at all I know that Donald Trump was here
yesterday having a rally down in [ __ ]
Anaheim which I thought was pretty
perfect for him to be heading down
towards Orange County with whatever the
[ __ ] it is on his head to talk to a
bunch of people that you know whatever
the [ __ ] they did to their face you know
I swear to god Hollywood get such get so
much [ __ ] for like you know like
everybody out here has plastic surgery
I'm not saying they don't but at least
it's decent Jesus Christ you go down to
[ __ ] Orange County with all those
Real Housewives and those what Bruce
Jenner looking dudes you know what I
mean member Bruce was still Bruce
everyone Caitlyn was still Bruce and to
do that his eyes done you know in the
nose and all that they all had like
those [ __ ] I think I did a bit about
that my acting I will have the Bruce
Jenner eyes I thought it was [ __ ] I
was you know you know my wife would
watch The Real Housewives of Housewives
of Orange County I'd be like all right
they picked the six biggest psycho
couples they could find people down here
don't look like this and then I went
down to Irvine I was playing The Improv
and I walked around the mall and I was
like wait a minute these [ __ ] people
I don't know what they're doing out here
I think when you get into warmer client
climates and people have to wear less
clothes they really start doing the
plastic surgery [ __ ] you know what I
mean
all you guys in those winter climates
you can hide in your puffy coats you
know sports coat button-down shirt I'll
never forget that when I used to work in
a warehouse when I was a young lad full
head of hair
[ __ ] ABS the whole thing half as many
freckles you know sunny outlook on life
I was a long time ago I remember once a
year we'd have the company picnic and
all these [ __ ] suits who look like
they were in the least halfway decent
shape they'd showed up they show up at
t-shirts and holy [ __ ] Jesus Christ the
[ __ ] rolls just [ __ ] spilling up
pushing out the [ __ ] t-shirt it was
horrific I just remember looking these
people going this guy's running a
company this time I've taken orders from
this type of [ __ ] and they could feel it
too
they could feel it they felt the eyes
looking at him shame you could shame
good fat shame people back in 88 89 not
anymore not anymore
now I'm now I'm the problem right it's
not that [ __ ] 8,000 calories a day
you know what happened to them when they
were six that's why they're eating
[ __ ] ice cream with candy bars in it
um sorry
anyways let's plow ahead here yeah so I
have absolutely no idea what the [ __ ] is
going on and anywhere at anytime
anything all I know is I'm in a [ __ ]
writers room not evidently meet me in
st. Louie Louie meet me at the fair
evidently my st. Louis Blues lost last
night you know they came back they tied
it up for games of two games to two and
that's the last game I saw cuz I've been
stuck in this [ __ ] room and I forgot
to tape the last couple of times you
know cuz we're you know we had one every
once in a while you just have a [ __ ]
story and you're trying to do it
everybody's got 15,000 notes you know
this isn't tracking it's not on the page
I don't think we earned this what's the
motivation you got to raise the stakes
and for those of you not in the business
that means you're not going to see
anybody you love for the next 48 hours
so I missed everything evidently
according to people on Twitter the
Sharks gave the bluesy all right they're
fret and game five and six sit down and
shut the [ __ ] up my condolences to Blues
fans
I know you wanted more but a great
season you know you beat the [ __ ]
Blues you beat the [ __ ] stars and
then you lost to the [ __ ] sharks all
right and I believe it was Meat Loaf who
said two out of three sorry yeah that's
[ __ ] brutal man especially when you
get that deep into the playoffs and then
it's just [ __ ] over and then you just
sit man like now what do I do
well you live in st. Louis this is what
you do you go to a Cardinals game and
you watch the Rams pack up and leave
your city and this is what you should do
rather than crying in you [ __ ] Peyton
Manning partially owned beer
what you should do is uh you guys got to
[ __ ] talk to the Arizona Cardinals
tell them to come back you know I mean
that's what I would do I would you built
now I wouldn't I wouldn't even know how
to begin I wouldn't rather begin to go
about doing something like that yeah I
mean I would have no idea I have no idea
how to go about anything I'm one of
those [ __ ] guys you you should do you
should flow can do this oh yeah how do
you how do you do that you know I'm like
I'm like Donald Trump except I'm not
running for president
you know I'll build a [ __ ] wall clean
here in Mexico I'm gonna make Mexico pay
for yeah yeah how you gonna do that
Donald the [ __ ] guy I can you [ __ ]
believe that that I mean it's [ __ ] it
it's been in Hillary Clinton I cannot
believe people are going to [ __ ] a vote
for either one of them I just cannot
[ __ ] believe it
I'm [ __ ] believable they'll vote for
Hillary Clinton they'll put her in
[ __ ] office and then [ __ ] that
nothing changed how many [ __ ] times
remember that [ __ ] I was going to
[ __ ] we got a new guy we got hope
he's going to end the war close down
Guantanamo Bay that's an [ __ ] chair
nothing changed it's exact [ __ ] same
thing then you got this [ __ ] jerk-off
who just all he just says is no matter
what you bring up hey Donald what's up
with your shirt this is the best shirt I
have the best shirts I'll have the best
shirts of any president ever and it's a
[ __ ] zillion people losing their
[ __ ] minds going this guy this guy's
going to turn it around
I guess he said the other day he took
her physically 69 years old and he said
the doctor said he had the I had he said
I had the I have the best body the best
body of any 69 year old he's ever seen
like how do you not see like you know
what he's like remember that guy who
wrote the twist caramel famous let's do
the twist right and then next summer he
comes out eight right another hit song
twist again
like we did last summer it's the same
[ __ ] song the guy actually brough
reference back like you know do you
remember when I wrote the same song it
was a year ago the [ __ ] was that guy's
name I know it wasn't Charlie pride
Chubby Checker you know what's worse
about any time to bring up chubby
Checker's and somebody always has to
tell you the story of how he got his
name well you know there was Fats Domino
so they said fat chubby Domino checker
yes everybody's heard that story
we all saw Dick Clark tell that story
and then everybody told it in the
[ __ ] bar [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway so so I haven't given you guys
the update on my sciatica sciatica
sciatica I think I found the cure for it
I have not sat down for more than
[ __ ] I don't know six seconds for the
last like 48 hours and it seems to be
doing wonders for me that's the hardest
thing about having sciatica other when I
Drive to the [ __ ] office and come
back I basically stand up in the writers
room and when I'm sick of standing I
just lay down on the floor like one of
those [ __ ] animals at the airport
some of the pictures you guys are
sending me to a [ __ ] hilarious this
guy sent me one with this guy was like
you know they have the roller chairs he
was sleeping underneath them like
perpendicular to them so he had his legs
his ass and his lower back were
underneath the chair laying on his front
and then he was like holding on to like
his hooded sweatshirt that he was using
as a pillow
he had that all wrapped with his head on
the side like like a little kid sleeping
with the stuffed animal I mean how long
is your flight been delayed that you you
just lost that much I don't know respect
for yourself but you can [ __ ] it late I
mean who's kidding no I mean I get on a
plane every once in a while the long
[ __ ] flight you know you might kick
your shoes off you got your socks on you
keep your socks on top of your shoes you
might do something like that for a
minute provided your feet don't [ __ ]
stink
provided you took a shower that day you
got on some [ __ ] fairly new sucks and
a fairly new pair of sneakers nothing
wrong with that but Jesus Christ you
started walking around the [ __ ] plane
going into the bathroom animals so
anyways anyway let me know yeah let me
get back to the sports here so the Blues
are knocked out the Sharks have made
their first final the Cavs kick the [ __ ]
out of the the Raptors as far as I know
and I've only you know like I said I
just watch highlights of this [ __ ]
dumbest [ __ ] move was the Raptors to
start doing the wagon the finger why
would you do that you know hey we're
finally starting to win here why don't
we piss off the Cavs and get them more
motivated they only have LeBron [ __ ]
James you know and OKC is in the process
of raping the [ __ ] of a the California
seals who they playing Golden State
Warriors Jesus Christ I've missed all of
it and I don't know anybody on any
[ __ ] team I mean other than the stars
I know those guys so I'm going to shut
up about it but I am tonight I'm going
to tape Game seven of the Penn's
lightning and I'm also going to take the
the OKC game because I want to see if
they're going to close out the Warriors
and then you know you know it's funny
all I need to do is just watch
highlights because you could still host
a sports show you know I got to tell you
right now or mobile upon the whoever
makes the finals in East let's say
Cleveland wins also if I'm not Cleveland
Cavaliers or I got to be concerned with
the Thunder of Oklahoma City considered
a big disperse any people warriors you
know to perennial favorite soloist
that's amazing the [ __ ] that they're
doing out there I wish I was watching it
and I didn't so I'm going to shut up
about it
all right before it's any more
excruciating to all you [ __ ] out there
yes well we're sitting there out right
in the [ __ ] show and there's all
these goddamn [ __ ] like stormtroopers
driving up and down the street if you
see those those [ __ ] blue
tics cops like this the riot gear once
you know that you'd think you'd only see
them you think you'd only see them in my
countries where they have like a
dictator you know where the truck is
driving down the street and they're
standing on the outside of it holding on
to it like just just way way over the
top like what the [ __ ] I thought I lived
in a democracy what the [ __ ] is that
they were driving over to like Jimmy
Kimmel because Trump was going to go
over there and say that he was the
greatest panel guest ever and then
[ __ ] driving over there like lunatics
one of the biggest [ __ ] things ever
is that in this country you're allowed
to protest it's such [ __ ] you're not
you show up the protest you stand in
there with your sign and then the cops
come down and they beat the [ __ ] out of
you that's basically what happens or you
file for a permit and they tell you
where you can protest and it's down the
street and up over a [ __ ] hill and if
we even remotely raised your voice you
get a billy club to the face and that's
pretty much every single [ __ ] country
out there that considers itself a
democracy now the ones that have a
[ __ ] dictator you're not even allowed
to do it they just come out and they
shoot you so I guess you know compared
to getting shot it's [ __ ]
unbelievable chanting with signs I'm not
talking about the people start jumping
on cop cars because those are the guys
that they always show but even if you
don't do that they just come down and
they beat the [ __ ] out of you I'd hate
to have that job as a cop it's got to be
so weird driving down there going like
wait a minute these are fellow Americans
they're protesting this is the sign of a
healthy democracy and then you got your
guy when I tear you to slam the club on
their [ __ ] head yeah you don't ask me
how what they had like all these [ __ ]
trucks and she was flying up and down
the [ __ ] Street you know and then
they'll put it on the news
they'll be eight people that were
flipping the [ __ ] out and that's all
they're going to show and then the other
thousand that showed up and we're just
short of stand-in there and they're all
going to get defined by them you know it
works well I guess I'm doing that to the
cops right defining them by all the ones
that beat the [ __ ] out of them that's
what I like to do people I like to make
a point and then I like to just
completely [ __ ] destroy everything
that I said you know what this podcast
just bejust just be called the I have no
answers I have arguments but I have no
answers if you guys visited the all
things comedy website ATC comm if you've
been there lately well you should some
of the greatest podcasts on in the free
world are on there and appreciate its
link by check it out every once in a
while you could getting sick of this
podcast there's plenty other podcast to
listen to let me do a little bit of
[ __ ] reads here really quickly before
I [ __ ] or like idea 16:18 [ __ ]
minutes alright I gotta get moving here
all right here we go zip recruiter oh by
the way I can't tell you this I [ __ ]
I couldn't sleep last night right so
like 4:50 in the morning I'm just I'm
gone I'm on Twitter for whatever reason
I'm just [ __ ] looking at [ __ ] and I
put my phone on silence and I turned all
the volume down cuz me is sleeping next
to me and then there was a video and I
clicked on it I thought because
everything was off that I could just
[ __ ] watch it with the sound down you
know I was watching all those things
where people somebody falls down and
they put it to a song you know and so
there was somebody doing like those
[ __ ] you know a burnout spinning
around and [ __ ] and [ __ ] slammed into
this guy so I wanted to hear what song
they put it to I didn't want to see that
just one of the screen to be bigger so I
could [ __ ] see it and I press play
and it came on full blast and my wife
just goes Jesus Christ what what the
[ __ ] I flipped out I was like sorry
sorry sorry
and then she immediately went back to
sleep and then for another half hour you
know I'm still on the phone because I
can't sleep and then I hit another one
like an [ __ ] wasn't thinking I just
wanted to see what happened to this
person and she [ __ ] sat up and she
literally did the Ralph Kramden she just
goes out out did that the [ __ ] door
and I wanted to start laughing but I
knew she was going to get mad at me man
she just went back to sleep and I didn't
leave but I'm waiting for her to wake up
so I can tell her that she did that
depending on how tired she is you know
she might be pissed at me
might still be pissed at me you know
what that's one of those later in the
day once at the end of the day when she
can go to sleep I'll [ __ ] bring it up
alright here we go oh look everybody
it's our old friend zip recruiter are
you hiring do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidates
posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates today
if you want to find the perfect hire you
need to post your job on all the top job
sites and now you can with zip but
guru.com you can post your jobs to 100
plus job sites including social media
networks like Facebook and Twitter all
with the single click you're lazy prick
find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into a zip rip
startup code is easy to use interface I
don't know what an interface is I said
that's one of those [ __ ] computer
words interface no juggling he punched
our interface no juggling emails or
calls to your office quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person fast find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by over hang on
a thousand businesses and right now
listeners can tries it but Krita for
free by going to recruit accom / / that
zip recruited comm / bro hey zip
recruited contract for all right Alex
helix what is it about buying a mattress
that leaves you feeling violated why
would you bring up mattress and violate
it why would you say that in the same
sentence Jesus Christ what is it about
it I don't know you wore loose jeans and
bent over to see how much the mattress
cost I have no idea
let's read more copy and find out is it
the pushy salespeople okay we got
mattress violated now this person's
being pushy the fake Presidents Day sale
or the fact that you know you'll regret
what you bought as you do the walk of
shame out of the mattress store walk of
shame I give you [ __ ] Bank somebody
right now you're wondering why those
days are over thanks to helic sleep
where you can buy a mattress online
customized for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands go to helix
sleep calm answer a few simple questions
and HELOCs creates you cuffs create your
custom sleep profile to build you your
perfect mattress the result did you ask
evidently their customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality
your mattress will arrive at your door
in about a week and shipping is 100%
free you have 100 nights to try it out
do what you want on it and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free with
rubber gloves and give you a hundred
percent refund no questions asked it's
like it never happened
that's this copy is so [ __ ] creepy
you know you can do whatever you want on
this mattress toilet for a hundred
nights will show up we're not asking any
questions we don't want to know what
happens and then what do they do they
recycle it in a third world like an old
cell phone if you do love your hellix
mattress keep it and your dignity that's
why everyone from GQ magazine to forbes
are all talking about helix sleep go to
hellix leet comm slash berth and get $50
off your order
that's helix sleep comm slash bar Hey
hellix leap comm slash bar that's h e li
x alright how many more of these [ __ ]
things i got here alright the next one
score big all right
you paying too much for tickets between
all the markups and last
inconvenient charges even print and Hum
fees are you [ __ ] kidding me over
here you end up paying courtside prices
for nosebleed seats score big is here to
change that did you know that 40% of all
live event tickets go unsold and did you
know there's a place to get these seats
at huge savings it's called score big
well then you bought them how did you
get them the [ __ ] team just gave them
to you
I really don't understand what that
means score bid works directly with your
favorite teams ah that's how it works an
artist to get their unsold seats at
unpublished prices only with score so
that's when you know you [ __ ] not
selling any tickets when score big goes
hey you want me to take half the arena
off your hands
you non-selling [ __ ] only with score big
can you name a ticket price and be
guaranteed a table below box-office up
to 60% off here's what you do well what
do you do to you you buy up all the
tickets Ashlee Simpson didn't sell I
mean is this going to be [ __ ] people
want to see one go to score big I don't
think Bruce Springsteen has to score big
once go to one go to score big calm or
download the new score big app for your
iPhone and find the event in seats you
want to make an offer with score Biggs
name a ticket price feature 3 get an
instant answer and save up to 60% on
your tickets I got a question if you
[ __ ] buying up 40% of the tickets go
on sold there's no way that happens at
Bruce Springsteen Beyonce all those huge
acts so you not sell those who you sell
it for the NSYNC reunion reunion yeah
NSYNC reunion sands [ __ ] Justin
Timberlake so all the original people
except the one that hit big never any
fees and shipping is always free you can
count on unbeatable prices and great
seats and when you're in great seats you
can actually enjoy the game or the show
all the more next time you see any game
or show go to score big first and see
how you can save how much you can save
for the easiest way to save on tickets
download the new score a big app for
your iPhone like I said [ __ ] 10
minutes ago and to promo code bird
checkout and you'll save $20 off your
first ticket price no iPhone nope
get $20 off on line 2 at score big calm
that score big calm promo code burr hey
why not why not write can't all be
what's that other one
everybody always goes to stop hub right
it's good that there'll be another
person out there scalping tickets right
all right Club W Club GI be my daddy
will be more than G it delivers wind
straight to your door we send you wine
that is personalized to your own palate
tastes through our palate quiz our
recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle you rate
we work with top winemakers and growers
from around the world directly make our
to make our all of our own wine our $13
bottles would normally retail for 20
bucks plus more than $20 I think is what
they're trying to say that you choose
the type and quantity of the bottles
with no membership fee or cancellation
fee 100% satisfaction guarantee creative
we partner with local artists to develop
wine labels that are unique works of art
right now at Club W hey I can speak
Spanish is offering listening listeners
$20 off your first order when you go to
club W I wouldn't build a wall dot-com /
/ and it gets even better I know you all
hate paying for shipping so Club W East
Killeen will actually pay for your
shipping on orders of four bottles or
more so take something off your to-do
list just go to Club Debbie I never went
to class
dot-com / Berg to get $20 off your first
order now that's Club Debbie and weapons
of mass destruction calm / burn all
right that's it and we're out we're out
anyways what the [ __ ] can I finish on I
really don't have anything to finish on
other than I'm excited that we're doing
the table read for number five next week
we write all week we don't have a table
read and then three weeks in a row we do
episode six seven eight week off just
writing no table read and then nine ten
and then I'm [ __ ] done in the writers
room and maybe my [ __ ] ass over here
can [ __ ] stop sending
electric jokes down my [ __ ] leg
laying down to the room now guy I feel
like [ __ ] like some Howard Hughes
without the money
this [ __ ] Wolfman nails you know I
saw some of the other day when I was in
the airport they were playing classical
guitar you know what I mean and it
sounded beautiful but the only thing
that sucks about playing classical
guitar is you got to grow your nails
like a [ __ ] wolf man you know one one
of your hands and it's all good when
you're sitting down playing guitar but
the second you put your guitar down you
just
it looks [ __ ] gross am I out of my
mind I guess that's no reason to stop
there's a few instruments you always
have to pay the price for like trumpet
trumpets one of them you know you start
playing the trumpet you get that [ __ ]
callus on your onion on your lip you
know it's one of my favorite instruments
ever
I love the [ __ ] trumpet but I would
never play Pet play it because I wasn't
willing to pay the price and plus I knew
I'd only be okay at it who wants to be
okay with it [ __ ] trumpet Callas not
this guy I'll tell you that right now
all right now here we go I'm gonna give
you my predictions for all the games
sixes and sevens out there and you can
take all of these predictions to the
bank and they won't give you [ __ ] for
them because I haven't watched any of
these series the goal of the Golden
State Warriors will win the next game
out Willy I don't know I didn't see the
game all I know is everybody said the
exact same thing I'll tell you this team
is a lot longer and a lot more talented
than they're used to seeing everybody
get a version of that I guess they're
long and they're talented and the
Warriors haven't seen anything like this
even though they played Oklahoma during
the regular season but I don't think
they were looking at them all right the
Tampa Bay Lightning will win Game seven
tonight all right so I feel like I'm
over two already and what else we got
the Cavs
oh the Cavs win in the next one that
[ __ ] series is over you don't [ __ ]
wag your finger and [ __ ] LeBron James
face or any of his teammates oh yeah do
you [ __ ] mind you know all these
[ __ ] actors running around bulking up
putting on their [ __ ] underoos
playing these superheroes right and all
these [ __ ] nerds going down to
[ __ ] check who could [ __ ] to win
the Hulk or Captain America and what
about Thor well he's going to stupid he
just has a hat and a hammer you know you
cut his hair his [ __ ] hammer breaks
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and
then you got these [ __ ] Comic Con
[ __ ] who actually dressed like
superheroes for real and walk around
trying to stop crime you don't I mean
because they just so want these
superheroes to be real well just go to a
Cavs game you stupid [ __ ] and watch
LeBron James okay LeBron James could
grab Batman and Robin in one [ __ ]
hand throw him through a plate-glass
window and he'd still get the n1 if
someone was hanging up his other [ __ ]
arm okay just go buy a ticket and sit
down like a [ __ ] gentleman stop
standing in line with [ __ ] 50 people
dressed like Chewbacca and Aquaman down
in San Diego whatever the [ __ ] you go so
you can sit down and talk to the cast of
I don't [ __ ] in one of those goddamn
shows what is what is what is a what is
a car I guess mine's a comic con show
huh now that I think about it Jesus I
hope they don't play that audio if we
ever do that show well maybe they do
what are they gonna do well throw some
of their uh action figures still in the
box at me you know why it's worth more
if it's still in the box
I can't say what I can't say oh you know
why [ __ ] weirdos you know it hasn't
been anywhere disgusting um happy Red
Nose Day what is this here a people sent
me this Twitter is for kids you
red-nosed [ __ ] oh so he just told me
what the Red Nosed thing is for it goes
it's for kids
oh is that what it's for it's for kids
all that explains it
I don't know why I'm such a douche but I
[ __ ] cannot stand I can't [ __ ]
stick when a bunch of celebrities get
behind a [ __ ] cause and there's a
[ __ ] ribbon or a goddamn nose and
they don't know why I just it drives I
know it's a good cause I'm behind the
cause but I [ __ ] hate it and then
everybody's got to find their own unique
way to have the nose on their face how
they're gonna [ __ ] hold it it should
it just drives me up the [ __ ] wall
that and famous people telling me who to
vote for oh you know what I didn't know
who to vote for and then you told me I
mean I guess I'd [ __ ] about it but I'm
not telling you who to vote for I don't
[ __ ] know like make a [ __ ] 20
minute video here's why you should vote
for [ __ ] Freddie [ __ ] you know
we're running out of water shut up you
know what's funny about what I just said
I could literally just stare in a mirror
and say that to myself in a lot of ways
right I never tell you [ __ ] who to vote
for I just make fun of the people you do
vote for that's what I do you want some
comb-over orange haired [ __ ] why don't
you just vote for me instead of Donald
Trump the [ __ ] is wrong with you I have
the greatest podcast ever nobody tells
the [ __ ] joke like me this club owner
told me F in 40 years of running a club
he's never seen [ __ ] jokes like my [ __ ]
jokes speaking of which I'm actually
going to bed both where the [ __ ] you
want to vote for I don't give a [ __ ]
it's not going to change anything we're
a bunch of animals and we're doomed to
destroy each other so you know get
yourself a dog and a hobby you know
find somebody you like treat them nice
said does it'll be great they'll stay
with you and when the whole thing goes
down you'll have someone to hug Jesus
anyway I said that made me lose my
complete train of thought oh tonight
tonight tonight tonight what was Phil
Collins thinking in the 80s Jesus Christ
he's such a great musician some of the
worst [ __ ] songs
after after uh I can't feed it comin
then all the Sun he was doing you can't
hurry love
after you can't hurry love then did that
song easy lover was decent and then it
just went off the [ __ ] Ralph sis to
do that when we use yelling at you you
know telling us to think twice because
it's another day for you and me in
Paradise you know when you see a
homeless person it's like hey [ __ ]
you know the way I'm living compared to
the way yo livin you don't need to look
at a homeless guy just look at me you
feel lucky when you look at me you don't
have to go all the way down to that
level do you your [ __ ] castle
tonight I'm going to be down at the
comedy still doing a benefit for kids
that's another one but I won't be
wearing a red nose but I will be jumping
around like a [ __ ] clown this is for
you know what I don't know what it's for
it's for sick kids and hospitals I have
no idea all I know is whoever put it
together I don't know I trust Steve
Simone I trust the guy so I act I
figured you know I figured Tommy up and
up
who knows I don't [ __ ] I don't
pretend to know things hey is anybody
out there who listens to this are you
one of those [ __ ] riot police guys
that rides on the outside of the truck
and when you do it as much as your
adrenaline is going up do you ever just
think of how [ __ ] ridiculous is you
know like what are we doing here we got
to get over to Jimmy Kimmel Donald Trump
is there what's going to happen uh
alright I think I I think I pissed off
enough people with this one alright go
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and I
will talk to you on Monday and like I
said you can take all of those
predictions to the bank
[Music]
Oh No
hey what's going on it's bill burr yeah
isn't that exciting it's the it's the
Monday morning podcast how are you
thanks for coming to my page and thank
you for listening and thank you
this Memorial Day so here we go
something nice thank you to all the men
and women who are serving this country
right now sweating their asses off over
there in Iraq I don't know what you're
supposed to say today do you say happy
Memorial Day I don't think you do
that doesn't seem fitting I don't know
what I'm trying to see if there's a
Memorial Day Parade out here in LA and
if so where would it be you don't to me
and you will Memorial Day Parade is a
very serious thing so I can't picture
the parade going down sunset honoring
the fallen men and women who've served
this country as the parade goes by the
[ __ ] saddle ranch you know there's
two [ __ ] are watching some [ __ ] head
write a fake horse you know what I mean
I just don't know where they would have
it out here I'm really not up on the
parades out here in LA since I moved out
here I'm melting at the gay pride parade
I know that's a Halloween someone's
always hilarious and confusing I've
never understood the gay pride parade
you know they spend [ __ ] 51 weeks out
of the year trying to be like look we're
normal we're just born this way okay for
the love of God stop tying us to fence
posts in Wyoming
all right we're not against God we just
wired this way you know and then they
they have the gay pride parade you think
they come down the street you know try
and look a little bit respectable or
what happens everybody's coming down the
street with a dick in their hand they
get [ __ ] I just don't get it you know
it's just too goddamn free-for-all
the [ __ ] spectacle look I definitely
recommend seeing it you ever want to
just if you ever wanted to see what 300
would look like if that's not looks like
it looks like that movie 300 with dildos
because everybody shredded I don't know
what gate why doesn't a gay guy put out
like a [ __ ] exercise video you know
what I mean it's always these these uh
he's half a [ __ ] guys who actually
heterosexual now we stand on the beach
nobody is more shredded than those those
gay dudes I don't know what it is so
there are their weights in those dildos
is that what it is do you [ __ ] room
for the wall and you do pull-ups or
something I'll speak on that [ __ ] I know
what a few weeks ago I was talking about
you know wanting to get in shape and
actually I you know some about that p90x
system and a couple people said it was
[ __ ] ever the people said that they
liked it all I know is like you know 200
bucks and like 58 DVDs I was like a tiny
life series you know on how to get abs
or something and it was just too
overwhelming and I go in the road too
much so I found the solution I went
online and I bought some I bought wings
you know those rings with that gymnast
use I'm going to put up a channel bar
today and I swear to God by the end of
the year I'm going to learn how to do a
[ __ ] Iron Cross and I just watched
that gymnastic [ __ ] and I missed nobody
is more shredded than those goods and
there's something I like about being
able to lift your own body weight you
know I mean that we know if you can like
climb up a [ __ ] building I think
that's way better than being able to
benchpress a car maybe it depends on the
situation that you're in you know some
fat [ __ ] sitting on your chest
going what do you do oh will you do
about it we're gonna do like I guess
then if you could bench 400 pounds that
would be like a good thing but I don't
know house fire you being chased by
somebody if you can go up the [ __ ]
building like spider-man I think that I
think that that's I have to think that
that that's always better that'd be a
cool thing Jesus Christ I can't get it
out bill I'm like I think I think I did
it I thought you said I thought you said
you wanted one spider yeah so see if I
can get you the website here this is
what this is this is what this broadcast
is becoming it's becoming me informing
you on the [ __ ] whacked-out [ __ ] that
I do all right this is training rings is
where I want to and W training rings
calm and check it out man I want to be
able to do one of those muscle ups you
know what I'm gonna start wearing really
tight t-shirts on on stage and then I'll
be ready for the gay pride parade Hey
look at that I brought a full circle all
right all right before I get to the
podcast those of you who are new to my
podcast I basically I do one of these
every week and people send me advice
sometimes people ask me advice people
send me questions I try to ask for them
answer them I mean best of my ability I
don't know and you know I don't read I
just sort of started talking so don't
really listen to me just I hope it make
you laugh or some [ __ ] and I hype
upcoming [ __ ] that I have like this week
May 24th I have a real busy week this
week May 24th the next installment of
the uninformed show with bill burr and
Joe DeRosa my radio show our radio show
me and Joe that we do on XM 202 is going
to be this Saturday night May 24th on XM
202 from 9 p.m. to 12 midnight I'm going
to be a Caroline's comedy club this week
but it's going to be weird I'm going to
be there Thursday not on Friday Saturday
and Sunday why aren't you going to be
there on on Friday bill because I have
to fly back to LA because I'm doing
stand-up on an award show oh my god are
you going to be doing stand-up at the
Oscars now
I'm going to be doing stand-up at the
Spike TV Awards Show I know I never
heard of it either but uh Mexican I
don't know
looks like Thai never got to do an award
show so let you guys know when and when
that uh one that's going to be and as
usual that that part of the podcast
sucks
whenever I hike what I have coming up
the whole thing starts to grind to a
halt I don't know and then I never have
half the [ __ ] information it's
ridiculous so all right before I get
into my rant for the week
I actually cuz it is Memorial Day and I
actually got a really cool email from
somebody who's over there I don't know
if they're in the army of the Marines
I'm assuming it's one of those two
branches because they're they appeared
to be on the ground over there says I
hope to get back to the states and come
to see you sometime quick story I was on
a mission the other day and I picked up
the radio and called to my lead truck
and said is that Tesco in your eggs the
other tactical commander said it's
asparagus there's a little bit of humor
for us
good stuff [ __ ] you later bill how
[ __ ] cool is that huh somebody's
talking over there in Fallujah sweeping
out the houses or whatever the hell you
do you know to a couple of my jokes I
was out one of the coolest emails I ever
got and actually have the name of the
guy who sent me that so when you get
back safe I'm going to hook you up at a
show all the rest of you comes with some
of this don't start sending me emails
pretending that you're over there just
so I can give you a couple of free
tickets next time I play Slappy's and
[ __ ] Omaha Nebraska
alright that's bad karma it's bad
[ __ ] Karma alright alright here's my
[ __ ] rant for the week all right
people and I'm going to try to move a in
calm throughout this without losing my
[ __ ] because I think it's a very
important thing that a lot of people are
dealing with and I'd much rather try to
get the information out and they may in
a nice calm way that way my message will
be heard and I won't and I won't seem
like a psycho
all right forget about the fact that I
to myself for half an hour every week on
these [ __ ] pigs okay so last week I
was flying to New York to do the HBO
show down and dirty with Jim Norton I
was very excited to do it anytime you
get to do HBO as a comedian is a big
thing a big big thing you know I would
like to see Jim Jim's the first guy from
my graduating class of comedians to get
a high profile stand-up gig like that so
it was really cool you know I was
anticipating see and post in the show
yada yada yada all that stuff okay I get
a first-class roundtrip ticket
I'm [ __ ] LAX no don't swear don't
swear they'll keep it nice I get a first
round first class round-trip ticket okay
counting to ten here from LAX to Newark
okay none of you guys have flown first
class I do what every once allow and I
get it get a [ __ ] TV show I don't do
it on regular basis because I did that
for one month and I got an $8,000 credit
card bill and I said you know what
I don't think coach is that bad so now I
got a free round-trip first-class ticket
did I make that point yet I think I did
so before I get on the plane I haven't
eaten but I'm thinking that doesn't
matter I have a first class round-trip
ticket I am going to be wined and dined
from LAX all the way to Newark New
Jersey I'm going to have [ __ ] wine
and dine that's what I'm going to have
probably get a foot massage you know
well hot towel maybe a quick little how
you doing you know first class and we
sit there and look down on the people as
they're getting into the back of the
plane acting like I'm running some big
successful business you know so again on
the plane I'm starving oh boy oh boy I'm
going to get something to eat
get on they hand me the menu okay and
one is I got two choices I can either
get an omelet with potatoes some fruit I
think a muffin and some orange juice or
cereal and I'm like wow that's sort of a
limited menu who the [ __ ] would get
cereal I'm going with the omelet who the
[ __ ] wouldn't get an omelet a vegan all
right you got me most you know generally
speaking everybody's going to get the
eggs so I go and I read the final line
of the menu and in parentheses it says
please accept our apologies if your
selection is not available and I was
like what the [ __ ] is about to happen
here what do you mean please accept our
apologies if your selection is not
available this is first [ __ ] class
all right that [ __ ] happens back in
coach when you sit and row 38f you know
then they run out of eggs they run out
of eggs in the back where they got
people [ __ ] stacked up like cordwood
you know that even a word a quart
quarter would isn't an amount of wood I
don't [ __ ] know that's a question for
you guys what is it is that a quarter
wood I cleared land one day and I heard
that expression and I just used it I
mean what the [ __ ] it is they got people
jam-packed in the back of the goddamn
airplane that's where you run out of
eggs you don't run out of [ __ ] eggs
in first class see I'm flipping out take
it down bill make sure your message is
heard okay so I'm sitting there they
start from the first class there's like
five rows I'm in row four I'm doing the
math and they're going through and you
know what nobody's picking cereal
coursed enough why would you pick cereal
when you can get anomaly alright
needless to say they get to my row and
they say what would you like mr. Burke
and I said I would like the omelet sir
and they say ooh I'm sorry um we're out
of eggs and
I go what do you mean you're out of eggs
yeah everybody ordered eggs and we're
out of eggs and I go what do you have
left knowing full well what they had
left and he goes we have cereal and a
bagel and I looked at the guy and I said
dude I paid for a first-class ticket
which I didn't of course I didn't got
for free but I don't give a [ __ ] all
right I want to make a point here I got
to go for big air I said I paid for a
first-class ticket I'm not eating cereal
and the guy was like I know I know I
know you're right we don't think it's
right but this is just how they do it
and I'm like what do you mean this is
how you do it I go there's like 12
people here in first-class how do you
run out of eggs this is first class
I'm not eating cereal the guy goes well
on on odd flights we start at the front
of first-class and on evens we start at
the back row of first-class it's like -
it's [ __ ] first-class it shouldn't be
a problem
I want [ __ ] eggs and he's like we I
didn't say [ __ ] I go I want eggs and
he's like well we have a cereal I'm
sorry sir and I just said you know what
I don't want anything right just started
pop so I'm sitting there fuming stomach
is growling I got a six hour flight I'm
starving to death and the widest goddamn
airplane speed I've ever sat in my life
so like two minutes goes by and I swear
to God the [ __ ] flight attendant
comes back and he goes um I just talked
to the pilot the captain of the airplane
and he said he already ate so you can
have his eggs and I was like what he
goes the pilot said you can have his
eggs I'm like I don't want his [ __ ]
eggs
I know what his [ __ ] eggs I want my
eggs this is first class there should be
enough [ __ ] eggs for me all right
in the goddamn piece of pilot he should
get eggs [ __ ] pancakes and waffles
whatever the [ __ ] he wants
I don't want that I don't want my pilot
up front [ __ ] starve you know passing
out all like edit and [ __ ] cuz he didn't
get any [ __ ] eggs it's ridiculous man
I mean how much [ __ ] money do you
have to make this is American Airlines
by the way this is American Airlines
this is how [ __ ] tight they are
they're trying to blame it on these
[ __ ] fuel prices oh by the way I
ended up taking the eggs because I was
so goddamn hungry and then I felt that
I'm sitting there eating and feeling
guilty like I'm eating the pilot eggs
and then inside I'm feeling like a
sellout because I'm thinking like maybe
they're thinking they're going to give
me these eggs and I'm not going to
[ __ ] fire off a goddamn letter on
their website which guy did [ __ ]
unreal American Airlines are did the
biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] of an airplane
ever an airline
do you remember my remix their song a
few weeks ago remember that for those of
you who didn't that was my new thing
because I'm sick of these goddamn
corporations and their [ __ ] they're
happy jingles as if screwing you over
every single day so I remix their song
then it went a little something like
this
we're American and I'm [ __ ] you in
the yes I did it as a joke two weeks ago
and I swear to god I've never been more
right in my life then the next day I get
off the goddamn plane [ __ ] big that I
find out they're going to charge $15 so
your first carry-on
now your first pair the first bag that
you check and they keep blaming it on
fuel prices how the price fuel keeps
going up and I'm telling you right now
as a passenger if you believe that [ __ ]
I don't know what to tell you they make
money off of misery okay 9/11 they made
money okay
I'm sure they're expensive
20 percent whatever but you know they
don't just raise it 20 they raise it 25
and it's the same thing with this
[ __ ] fuel this is my question
alright who's going to start it ok I'm
not starting it but I swear to God if
anybody out there starts it I'm going to
follow okay there has to be some sort of
[ __ ] pushback because I don't know
what's going on he's [ __ ] he's got
the incorporations it used to be the
customer's always right and somehow in
my lifetime it's going to you know [ __ ]
you and your mother customer that
survived you know when I went to fly
back my round-trip first-class ticket I
show up my [ __ ] flight is canceled
and rather than flying first-class
non-stop from Newark to LAX
I was now flying coach to Dallas and
then first-class from Dallas to LAX and
and there was no voucher they're like
yeah we're not offering anything it's
like six months ago I would have got a
[ __ ] if you [ __ ] me this bed and
she's just like now and Adam did not ask
for anything you got to call the 1-800
number then I call the 1-800 number like
now you have to talk to person that's
death and like [ __ ]
I just talked to the person that
definitely hung up as I said [ __ ] so
then I had to call back and in the end
of it all they gave me 150 bucks which
will buy like one third of a coach
ticket well once again I won't get any
[ __ ] eggs
so all I'm asking is who's going to
start it who's going to start the
[ __ ] you know we need we need like a
[ __ ] what's Charles Bronson's name in
those Deathwish movies Paul Kersey we
need a [ __ ] the airline version of
that Jesus Christ some I mean who the
[ __ ] wants to pay $15 to their first bag
that they check everybody knows that's
[ __ ] nobody wants to do it but we're
all going to do it because we're all
just by ourselves twisting in the wind
okay so if we all showed up the first
day June 15th of n where the [ __ ] it is
and you show up at the airport with
angry faces and torches like we're going
to go try to get Frankenstein guarantee
and none of us have to pay 15 bucks okay
I'm not trying to incite a riot here I'm
just saying somebody start passing out
the two-by-fours I'm down with it all
right I'm not going to lead it because I
procrastinate and everybody knows you
know they always chop off the head to
the body Falls okay if I learned
anything from the 1960s black white male
seem I'll if you [ __ ] with the deal you
have a convertible ride in your future
alright but some good things do happen
so [ __ ] I'm so pissed right now
can't [ __ ] believe that the pilots
eggs actually the pilot it can you
[ __ ] believe that thirty years ago
goddamn stewardesses they think it was
first of all they were all hot that's
for one thing okay it was a goddamn
glamorous job all right
he had a 1 in 10 chance of hooking up
with one of the hottie stewardesses
that's why people used to wear suits you
wanted to look it was like a nightclub
every 1000 people were smoking you
having a goddamn party in the [ __ ]
sky here's one for you you know what
first class used to be this is the
greatest story I ever heard as far as
first class this is what it used to be
as compared to my [ __ ] we're out of
eggs first-class experience Pan Am
airlines I'm dating myself here
all right Pan Am we used to fly too I
mean with John F Kennedy Airport I read
about this [ __ ] on the Internet right so
it's got to be true first of all the
MetLife building that's right above
Grand Central Station used to be the Pan
Am building so we used to fly
first-class to JFK Airport you got off
first class and you you didn't go to a
[ __ ] Town Car and sit in goddamn
traffic on the Li e or wherever the [ __ ]
you go through the Midtown Tunnel and
take an hour and a half which ruins the
first-class experience you got off the
[ __ ] plane at JFK Airport they put
you on a helicopter swear to God they
put you on a helicopter and they flew
you to the top of the Pan Am building
you got up drinks for waiting probably
more broads with those scarves tied
around their necks like [ __ ] dick
Cabot you get another [ __ ] then you
took the [ __ ] elevator down to the
first floor jumped in a cab you went to
your hotel pre herpes pre-aids here's
some penicillin have a good [ __ ] time
all right that was first class back then
then something happened where the wind
something happened where the wind tipped
over a helicopter and the blades went
flying down to the street and chop
somebody in half okay but that's beside
the point
I really did happen by the way I forget
who had chopped in half but he was the
son of somebody somebody obscurely
famous you know like the guy who
invented like the book marker or
something
all right Jesus quite some [ __ ]
winded after that story which brings me
to my first bit of advice if somebody
gave me this week bill taking naps can
really help me out when I get too
negative and agitated but this can be
hard for you since you fly so much
running and lifting weights also helps
me out too
oh thank you for that advice I don't
know I think the running and lifting
weights would help me out as you can
tell with my rage issues but taking naps
I can't do it like my brain wakes me up
I don't know how to shut it off so if
anybody out there knows how I can shut
this [ __ ] thing off all right
I'm really worked up here all right
here's I have some advice some of you
this is how there's a question I get
like every week people always give me
this on the safety people say I'm funny
how do I become a comedian
I must get access like 10 times a week
this is what you do right five minutes a
[ __ ] that you think is funny sign up for
an open mic when they call your name go
up there hang on for dear life spit out
as much of it as you can remember tape
you set go home listen to it keep the
jokes at work got get rid of the ones
that didn't and then write some more
jokes to take place take the place of
the ones that didn't work and then you
sign up for another open mic you repeat
the process and you just keep doing that
and then eventually you build an act
next thing you know you're a comedian
flying first-class to a dream TV gig
without any [ __ ] eggs although you
get eggs but we're gonna give you the
guilt trip you can have the pilot eggs
he'll just sit up there and be hungry
what da [ __ ] all right it's podcast I'm
sensing is getting a little long here
let me get on to the questions and I'll
get out of here and you guys can get on
with your Memorial days okay bill
another questionable one you always seem
to mention sports in your act I was
wondering if you were involved in any
fantasy sports leagues no I am NOT
fantasy sports leagues are for geeks I
[ __ ] I can't stand them they have
ruined sports talk in a bar people
aren't like affiliated with [ __ ]
teams anymore
you'll bring oh my god you see the
Vikings one year ago ticker ABC VCT
really really what else you have on your
fantasy team huh a girlfriend somebody
who satisfies you sexually Oh what else
you have a dream job we not [ __ ]
walled in by a cubicle now I don't play
fantasy sports weeks actually know what
I don't really know much about them I
find that sports picks up they take us
takes up too much of my time anyways so
I don't watch pregame I'm not in fantasy
sports leagues
I don't watch post games I don't listen
to any of those [ __ ] ranting raving
lunatics that ESPN has now if anybody on
ESPN for some reason listens to these
things why is every show become to
people screaming at each other and why
do you guys hype things up to such a
ridiculous [ __ ] level that it never
you know I mean like everywhere the
Patriots with six or now they're like
it's just the greatest team ever yeah
yeah I guess they are I mean let's
completely ignore the fact that the
Colts were thirteen and OH two years
earlier let's let's declare them the
glitz ask if they're the greatest team
ever when they're still [ __ ] twenty
games left in the season you dumb [ __ ]
all right um num2 bill which end of your
comedy crowd spectrum do you prefer to
put up with the douchebag frat guys who
drank so much they decide to try and
heckle you after your show while you're
signing CDs oh yeah I know this is that
Avenue in Chicago okay all are the older
men who came to the show with their
wives that are afraid to laugh at your
jokes because they want to get laid that
night um I definitely prefer to be the
older guys who don't laugh because they
want to get laid by their wife that
night because if I pick up on it it
usually ends up being a much funny
situation because I think I can make the
woman somehow feel guilty for doing what
she's doing I guess I don't know riff on
it that's more fun but as far in the guy
heckling you after the show because he
didn't have the balls to do it during
the show it's just sad and it always
makes me feel like that person actually
wanted to be a comedian they just never
had the ball
to do it and I'm watching the death of a
dream
wow that was darker okay question number
three bill is he / she a bad comedian if
they try to talk to the audience I've
noticed in the last few years the worst
comics are the ones that base their
commie comedy on hi where are you from
so they can goof on the audience void
[ __ ] machine w so they can goof on the
audience are the worst comics melt that
wasn't me that was him he wrote a bad
sentence there even the last time I saw
you were in Southern California the
improv the two people before you kept
trying to find ways to make fun of the
people in the audience as a comic do you
think that this is a sign that they are
a bad comic I would think it would turn
everyone else else off because they are
too worried about being talked to next
one time I was watching a taping of
Frasier in LA and 90% of the people got
up because the comic in the stands with
us kept ripping on everyone first of all
that's [ __ ] hilarious the guy doing
the audience warm-up was in between
takes of Frasier was just going what are
you guys a bunch of [ __ ] douche bags
and 90% of the crowd left I don't want
to be a [ __ ] here but uh I don't know
about 90% didn't like just like 30% I
would think if 90% of the studio
audience walked out at some point
somebody with a clipboard and a headset
would have walked over to the comics one
would have been like hey dude why don't
you [ __ ] tone it down a little bit
okay
Kelsey Grammer is getting a little
pissed because 90% of the crowd has left
can you stop calling calling them [ __ ]
you know I know what you're saying
though um what do I think it's hard
people working with you on the audience
yeah I definitely know what you mean
there's definitely guys who don't have
enough jokes so then they go hey where
you from what do you do a little that
job sucks but then there's other guys I
see [ __ ] with the crowd and they're
brilliant at it
I would just basically say if you don't
have any material and you suck at
playing to the crowd then yeah you suck
at it then you suck as a
absolutely but if you're good at it and
that's your thing I don't think there's
anything wrong with it
Jesus Christ I answered that like
Hillary Clinton well I think it could be
a good thing and a bad thing
Oh whatever just [ __ ] elect me all
right
has she given up yet Jesus Christ she's
like one of the [ __ ] she just won't
tap out she's like one of the Gracie's
they got like a [ __ ] arm Bend Ollie
Zack yeah I still think I'm doing good
think I'm gonna win I'll take some
that's the one thing I've learned about
this election I learned that I
completely do not give a [ __ ] about race
I really don't black white Puerto Rican
I don't give a [ __ ] if you make sense I
will vote for you right so my hatred of
women whoo [ __ ] unreal
I don't hate women
it's just get that [ __ ] voice good
lord man you know they gotta bring it
down the problem is is women they raise
their voice up because they try to do
with the guys think guys when they raise
their voice it has a commanding sound to
it women when they raise their voice up
they sound like a [ __ ] seagull so
what she needs to do is deliver her
speeches and a middle range maybe even
drop it down to a whisper a little bit
and I swear to god that's where the
female voice has power medium voice to a
whisper they can make a dick hard you
know you pick sides no you're not
thinking clearly you're gonna [ __ ]
vote for but when you're gay yeah yeah
when you're [ __ ] way up there people
are not going to hear your message
I talk more [ __ ] on this [ __ ] thing
alright the last question here we go
then immediate question um before bill
you spoke about us going home with you
you know hearing you all this is last
week's podcast when I parked my car in
the garage and I yeah we heard you walk
up the steps close the garage door which
made me think what's your take on
stalkers celebrity stalkers if you will
she look insulting me their celebrity
stalkers if you will celebrity in quotes
God knows I love the 80s doesn't count
as being a celebrity which it doesn't
you're right okay celebrity stalkers if
you will have you ever had one if you
did would you be flattered or freak the
[ __ ] out okay
no yeah obviously who the [ __ ] wants to
be stuck you don't I mean I don't know I
mean I wouldn't want to be stalked by
the hottest chick on the planet that's
how frightening stalkers are because no
matter how good-looking they are they
have that crazed yeah we think that that
that fatal attraction that I'm not going
to be ignored Michael whatever his
[ __ ] character's name was right then
you know what he should done
whenever I see that movie fatal
attraction she's like I'm not going to
be ignored and she sort of leans her
head down a little bit I always wanted
him to just hit her with like a [ __ ]
just a right cross on a fucked-up angle
like like Roy Jones member used to tell
the punches from those weird angles
maybe do like that little rooster hawk
and just [ __ ] crack you know yeah
there's your attention oh look at me I'm
like Dice Clay the end of this [ __ ]
thing um why am I doing this this is
just brutal
why why am i last you're not a woman
here in the amethyst is this is dumb
okay just because I'm not going to vote
for Hillary Clinton doesn't mean I hate
all women I just hate the sound of the
female voice in the high register I
think that that's what it is anyways let
me finish answering this question and
then I'll get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
that is what that is like then get
soccers freak me the [ __ ] out I don't
mind people who are really you know come
out to a show I've had a couple people
come on show and made t-shirts and that
kind of thing and they act a little zany
that doesn't bug me but you know later
on that night I don't you know roll over
in bed and all of a sudden they're
hovering outside my hotel window yeah
that would obviously freak me out
yeah I don't think anybody finds that
flattering okay I'm taking a very
serious toenail the sudden I'm starting
to get scared okay you happy that's what
your question did to me all right
I'm gonna go put on my chin up bar okay
that's what I'm doing and I'm actually
going to buy a piece of rope down at the
hardware store then I'm going to hang
from the [ __ ] bank and I won't be
able to [ __ ] climb up that son of a
[ __ ] and I know what you think and
we'll bill it's the [ __ ] I mean
putting and get like six feet of rope
now this is what you do you do get that
amount of rope but your [ __ ] actually
get more if you want to be able to tie
it up but you sit on the floor okay with
your legs straight out l-shaped and then
you pull yourself up just with your arms
and I'm telling you if you can [ __ ]
do that my goal is by November to
[ __ ] glue 10 like stands and put them
on top of each other and that's how I'm
going to end my show I need a hook
people okay I'm going to climb right up
the [ __ ] thing right out the roof get
on a helicopter fly one of those old Pan
Am ones that fly the [ __ ] out of the gig
and that's how I'm going to end it every
[ __ ] time
some do a big dramatic wave right as I
go through the ceiling of a funny ball
all right and that's it there you go
that's the podcast for the week please
please keep sending me the questions
please keep asking me or giving me
advice or whatever and I will talk to
you guys next week everybody have a
great week I'm a Caroline this week on
Thursday Saturday and Sunday Friday I'm
flying back to LA because I have to do
stand-up on a spike TV award show next
weekend the following weekend there'll
be a good night's comedy club in North
Carolina later on that monthly 19th
through the 21st I'll be at the punch
line and Atlanta Georgia
Hotlanta and I don't know where the [ __ ]
I'm going to be after that I just put up
a Miami Florida date
what else do I got coming up I got some
dates in September
I got Austin in October just go to Bill
Bird comm check all of them out my DVD
and my comedy special they're all coming
out in September that Jim Norton HBO
down and dirty with Jimmy Norton that's
also coming out in September and I'll
let you guys know next week when the
spike TV awards thing is coming out all
right that's it everybody has a bleak
thankful listen take it easy
[Music]
yeah
Oh
[Music]
you